اسامه ماذا عن الموقف في مروي كيف يتطور
كيف تتطور الامور
نعم كل عام وانتم بخير
عيد الفطر المبارك هذه المره ياتي على
مدينه مروي على غير العاده وفيه كثير من
التعقيدات ربما لان ما حدث بها في هذه
المدينه يعني هو غريب عليها واثر احدث
تاثيرات عميقه على الاقل تاثيرات النفسيه
قبل التاثيرات الميدانيه نحن الان داخل
احد المتنزهات السياحيه داخل مدينه مروي
في شمال السودان وهو منتزه ارض الحضارات
كما تشاهدون هذا المتنزه على غير العاده
ربما هو عنوان بارز لما يعني لطبيعه
الاحتفالات التي
تعود عليها الناس هنا في مدينه مروي وفي
غيرها من المدن المدن السودانيه ربما رغم
ان يعني هذه المتنزه في وضعه في واقعه
الطبيعي لا يخلو من
الباحثين عن الترفيه والسياحه خاصه
الاطفال تشاهدون اذا هذا هو المتنزه لا
يخلو تماما ولكن هناك اعداد قليله في
الواقع من الذين من رواد هذا المتنزه
تحدثنا مع اداره هذا المتنزه وذكر لنا بان
من الغريب ان يكون هذا المتنزه فيها مثل
هذا اليوم في اول ايام عيد الفطر المبارك
بهذا المستوى من الحضور
صحيح ان بعض الباحثين عن عن الترفيه في
هذا المساء طبعا الوقت هو الوقت المناسب
تماما في اي وقت طبيعي وفي اي ظروف طبيعيه
يعني
زياره مسلم مثل هذه المتنزهات تشاهدون
العاب جميعها الملحقه بهذا المتنزه متوقفه
تماما لا لشيء الا ولان
الرواد قليلون
وذكر لنا ذكرت لنا اداره المتنزه ان
الاثار السلبيه النفسيه على الاسر بسبب ما
يجري في البلاد عموما وفي منطقه مروي
خصوصا في خلال الايام القادمه ربما منعت
اغلب الاسر من الحضور الى هذا المتنزه
يكاد يكون خاوي هذا المتنزه
وعلى غير العاده
الباحثون عن الترفيه في هذه اللحظات
قليلون جدا بعضهم شباب لا وجود لاي اطفال
في هذا المتنزه رغم ان الاطفال في الوضع
الطبيعي
في اليوم الاول للعيد يعني تزدحم بهم هذه
المتنزهات ولكن الوضع فيما يبدو ان ما حدث
خلال الاسبوع الماضي في في غالب انحاء
البلاد هو ما تسبب في عزوف الحضور حضور
احضار الاسر لاطفالها حتى يعني يرفه عن
انفسهم ويدخلوا في نفوسهم البهجه والسرور
جاء هذا العيد فيه تعقيدات كثيره وفيه
استثناء
يعني يتعود عليه الناس عاده في ظروف
استثنائيه وفي ظروف بالغه التعقيد
يتمنى الكل هنا ان تزول الاثار النفسيه
لهذه الاحداث الداميه لكل السودان في
يعني ان يكون هذا المتلزه
مزدحم كعادته في في ايام الاعياد بعض
الناس يجلسون على الارض
ويتسامرون ربما يحاولون ان يتناسوا
بهذه بهذه المشاهد كل ما حدث ويحاولون
الرسم لوحه فيها شيء من الفرح خاصه وان
الحاجه ملحه بالنسبه
للناس والاطفال هنا على وجه الخصوص ان
يخرجوا ان يخرجوا من الاجواء التي صاحبت
داخل الايام الماضيه هذا القطار هو متوقف
طبعا تماما
وليس هناك اي لعبه
في هذا المتنزه تعمل
وربما خلال الايام القادمه اذا ما تغيرت
الظروف
والوضع النفسي للاسر تحسن
وربما يكون هذا الواقع واقع مختلف هؤلاء
يحاولون يعني اخراج انفسهم
من دائره القلق الذي شعروا به خلال الايام
الماضيه طبعا مدينه مروي ال- واجهه ظروف
انقاسيه خلال الايام الاولى للاشتباكات
المسلحه بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
كانت هناك سيطره حتى الان كامله لمنطقه
مرغي بالنسبه للجيش السوداني وكذلك وقال
الجيش طبعا انه يسيطر على مطار مروي
الدولي الذي تركزت فيه الاشتباكات المسلحه
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ربما وسائل اخراج الناس وخاصه الاطفال
المتلزق خالي تماما من الاطفال يحاول
الناس ما حضر في هذه اللحظات يحاول تناسي
مرارات وقسوه الايام الماضيه التي واجهو